[Music]
Kobe Bryant was the first to be honored
during the Oscars in memoriam segment on
Sunday
[Music]
bili Eilish and her brother Phineas
provided the soundtrack to the tribute
performing a haunting rendition of the
Beatles song yesterday as Kobe's photo
appeared on the screen behind them along
with these words from an interview he
did in 2008 quote life is too short to
get bogged down and be discouraged you
have to keep moving you have to keep
going
the legendary NBA star died in a
helicopter crash on January 26th
alongside his 13 year old daughter
Gianna and seven others Billie opened up
to et about honoring Kobe on the red
carpet ahead of her performance make
every time because when we were in
rehearsal and they run kind of what's
going to be playing it's like every time
I see his face I'm like Spike Lee also
paid tribute to the former LA Lakers
star sporting the team's signature
purple and gold colors as he presented
the Oscar for Best Director Jun and if
you look closely you'll notice Kobe's
number 24 stitched onto the lapels and
back of Lee's suit he even rocked a pair
of orange and black
Kobe Nike sneakers of course the 62 year
old has a special tie to Bryant in 2009
he directed the documentary Kobe doing
work and the Oscar goes to hair love and
the tributes didn't end there filmmaker
matthew cherry dedicated his trophy for
Best Animated Short to the black mamba
this award is dedicated to Kobe Bryant
may we all have a second act as great as
his was thank you a very full circle
move in 2018 Bryant won an Oscar for his
animated short deer basketball which was
based on a poem he wrote meanwhile the
tributes to Kobe his daughter and the
seven others killed in the January 26th
helicopter crash will continue later
this month a source tells ET a public
ceremony will be held on Monday February
24th at the Staples Center in downtown
Los Angeles
you